Okay, so we are back at the screen. We are
now on video 30 of the professional
trading masterclass video series. We
continue with our trade idea generation
process. And now we are going into the
world of qualitative processing. So
welcome to qualitative processing one.
Now, before we get going into qualitative
analysis, let's have a little reminder of
the context here. So in terms of
fundamental analysis, the evolution of the
quantitative and qualitative process. So
first of all, we have our quantitative
phase, which splits into two areas, our
quant discovery phase and our quant
evidence phase.
In quant discovery, we are relying on
forward looking metrics and valuation. We
identify positive and negative outliers
and everything else in between, such as
turnarounds or potential value traps.
In the quant evidence phase. In the quant
evidence phase, we look to our backwards
looking financial statements. And we ask
the question, do the financial statements
provide evidence to support valuation of
the positive and negative outliers that we
identified and discovered using our
forward looking metrics?
And then we move on to qualitative
analysis. And then we move on to
qualitative analysis. And what we focus on
is qualitative drivers of the business. So
we look at backwards and forwards looking
key performance indicators and the
management operating plan of the company.
So we identify the KPIs and the management
operating plan. And we ask the question,
do they provide evidence to support the
value of the business? And then we move on
to our qualitative analysis. And then we
move on to our qualitative analysis. And
what we focus on is qualitative drivers of
the business.
What we focus on is qualitative drivers of
the business. So we focus on qualitative
drivers of the business. So we look at
backwards and forwards looking key
performance indicators and the management
operating plan of the company. So we
identify the KPIs and the management
operating plan. And we ask the question,
do they provide evidence to support the
valuation of our positive and negative
outliers that we have identified in the
quant phase?
So at the stage when we reach qualitative
analysis, what has happened is, is that
we've discovered an outlier and we've
understood the supporting quantitative
evidence from the financial statements.
And as we've done that, we have probably
learned some of the basic information
about a stock.
So it's product and or service. So by
default, it's kind of unavoidable that
even when we're doing the backwards
looking quantitative process, where we're
looking at financial statements, we are by
default going to pick up some qualitative
information that is essentially part of a
qualitative process.
So this is where the quantitative
processes overlap. So there is overlap
between the quant and qualitative
processes at this juncture, because we are
continually asking the questions, and we
are continually looking for evidence to
support the valuation of the outlier that
we have identified.
So the next level quantitative and next
level quantitative and next level
qualitative, we are continuously seeking
evidence that gives us the full story and
the full picture in the stock, behind
valuation. And this involves both
backwards and forwards looking metrics.
When we move into the qualitative metrics.
When we move into the qualitative phase,
the first thing we are looking to do is to
identify key performance indicators of the
company. So in the quant phase, we used
forward looking valuation and growth
metrics to discover what the market likes
and dislikes in a sector and everything
else in between.
We also looked to the backwards, we also
looked to the backwards quantitative
financial statements for evidence to
support the outlier status of a stock that
we have discovered.
We now move on to the next stage, which is
the identification of a company's KPIs and
what the management operating plan of the
company actually is.
The first question is, why in the hell are
KPIs so important to us?
Well, when you see the profit and loss
account for a quarter or year end for a
particular company, it is a statement of
the results of the company.
By its very nature, it's backwards
looking. So they are the results from the
last quarter or the last year.
But there's something behind the results.
It's called a business.
Beneath the end result, there is something
that creates the result.
So there's a business and this business is
driven by the management operating plan
and it's measured by key performance
indicators, KPIs.
So the management operating plan drives
the results of the business.
However, it's the KPIs that measure the
effectiveness of the management operating
plan and the business that's behind
creating the results.
Now, unfortunately, there is no resource
where the management of a company
literally tell you line for line what
their management operating plan is.
What we have to do as traders is we have
to identify a company's KPIs and then
infer what the management operating plan
is by putting the pieces all together.
So this is what we're going to do in this
video for you with an example.
And then you can go off and just repeat
this process and use it as a template.
But first, we have to make some
assumptions. So we have a backdrop and we
have context.
So for the purposes of this exercise,
we're going to assume that you have found
what you think is a good quantitative
study.
You have a quantitative stock. So you've
been through the identification process
and the backwards looking quant.
So the financial statements and the stock
that you're looking at as a potential long
idea as increasing revenue and or earnings
growth relative to its peer group.
And the backdrop is that its valuation is
premium or superior to the sector.
Your next job then. And by default, you
will probably find out this information
anyway when you're looking at evidence in
the financial statements and trying to
understand what drives the valuation.
So you're going to have to find out during
that process what the company actually
does and has done in the past.
And also where you think the company is
potentially going in the future.
So we're also going to make the assumption
here that you've looked at all of the past
info on the company and now you know what
they do and what probably sets their
product and or service sets it apart from
the competition.
Now, some things we have to remember as
well as in terms of best discipline.
So remember, there will always be a reason
why the quant was good.
There is a reason why earnings growth and
or revenue growth is forecasted by the
market to be better than average of the
peer group.
There's also a reason why the market rates
the company higher via a higher than
average price earnings ratio and peg
ratio.
So there is a reason why people are
relatively putting dollars into the stock
at the expense of other similar
businesses.
There's also a reason why the market, the
market, the market, the market, the market
wants to own the stock at the expense of
other stocks that have inferior products
or services.
So the company is probably taking market
share in the sector.
Now, this phase where we are learning
about a stock, we have to understand it
always in the context of what constitutes
a trade idea.
So the first step when we're learning
about a stock is always to go to the
investors relations website of the company
and we start hoarding qualitative
information.
So we continue to learn what the company
does and why they are perceived to be
superior to their competition or peer
group.
What this is, is learning about the
company.
But don't forget, this is not generating a
trade idea.
Just simply learning about what a company
does and why it has a superior valuation,
what its product and service is.
That isn't a trade idea.
There's a big difference between learning
about the company, what it does and why it
is potentially superior versus learning
about whether the stock will actually go
up in the next 60 days.
Don't confuse the two exercises.
This is a big error amongst retail
traders.
A lot of people have the ability to go
through some processes and identify what a
good company is.
But a good company does not mean a good
stock.
So a trade idea is not an investment idea.
We are not in this business to look for
good companies and then just buy the stock
and hold forever.
We are traders.
Catalysts are required.
And of course, we are going to come on to
catalysts later.
So as we've been through that process of
learning about a stock, we have to
understand that we are learning the
information of the stock.
And the information alone doesn't qualify
it as a trade idea.
We are in the evidence gathering phase.
And obviously, that is a qualitative
process because we are gathering
qualitative information.
When we move into our qualitative
analysis, when we are looking at KPIs,
this is how we try to predict the future.
And this is done once we know the past and
we are fairly confident or very confident
that we know why the company has a
superior rating or better product or
service.
So the question to keep in mind when we
are going through the qualitative process,
when we are evidence gathering on forward
looking qualitative information, when we
are looking at KPIs and the management
operating plan, that question always is
how does the company's future look
compared to expectations?
So as mentioned previously, before we
looked at our backdrop of assumptions.
looked at our backdrop of assumptions, the
first part of the qualitative phase is to
identify what key performance indicators
are actually important to the company.
Now, back in the quantitative phase where
we looked at the financial statements of a
company for evidence to support our
forward looking valuations and growth
rates, we will have gone to the investor
relations website of the company to get
the financial statements.
Now, the investor relations websites of
public companies are incredibly useful in
the qualitative phase of the trade idea
generation process.
Why?
Because public companies have to, by order
of regulation, update investors
continuously on the state of their
business.
And they do this, obviously, through their
quarterly and annual earnings releases, of
course, but they also do this with verbal
and written communication in between
earnings releases.
So companies can choose to do the minimum
where they just release their quarterly
earnings reports or they can choose to do
more than the minimum.
So they can be very inactive with their
communication in between earnings releases
or they can actually be highly active
between earnings releases and engaging.
Now, we're going to come on to this a bit
later in the video series in the section
on catalysts.
At this stage of the process, what we are
seeking to identify is what drives the
business in a qualitative capacity beneath
the end result,
which is the hard numbers in the financial
statements.
So we're looking at the qualitative
elements of the business that drive the
quantitative results.
And the investor relations websites of
companies can provide us with an absolute
treasure trove of information to identify
key performance indicators and the
management operating plan.
Now, whenever we go to investor relations
websites and we are going through this
process of identifying KPIs, we need to
ask ourselves continuous questions.
So again, we are assuming here that you've
been through the quant process, you've
identified your outlier, you've been
through the backwards looking quant,
learning the stock info,
and then we're now going into the
qualitative phase.
So we have to keep viewing our work
through a particular lens in the same way
that we did during our previous processes.
So we need to keep asking ourselves the
question, why is earnings growth or
revenue growth so good or bad?
Why does the market value the company in
the way that it does?
Does the stock deserve to be on its
assigned premium or discount?
Will the company continue to report good
numbers or bad numbers as the case may be?
Beating expectations or missing
expectations as the case may be in revenue
and earnings?
Is this a high probability?
And we answer all of these questions via
the key performance indicators and the
management operating plan.
This is how companies measure themselves.
So how they give guidance to the market.
And it's how analysts measure the
company's performance to enable them to
forecast revenue and earnings outcomes.
So this is how analysts get their
expectations for revenue and earnings.
Now, we are going to go through now an
example of how to identify KPIs, key
performance indicators.
And the example that we're going to look
at is Zendesk.
And when we arrive at the qualitative
phase, we should have at least a basic
understanding of what the company actually
does.
So what does Zendesk do?
It is a customer relationship management,
a CRM software as a service SaaS company.
It is a business to business product and
it serves business to consumer businesses.
And its core function is helping to solve
customer issues faster.
So it gives a help desk platform to
businesses.
So what the software actually does, it
helps businesses in management of customer
communication through various channels
like email, web forms, chat, voice calls
and social media like Twitter, Facebook
and LinkedIn using an omni channel
ticketing system.
The software also has automation of
customer support processing and they're
utilizing various macros and other
automation tools.
And they also have customer self-service
tools that utilize bots for auto replies,
there's knowledge bases, there's customer
communities and FAQs, frequently asked
questions.
And where do we get all of this
information to learn about what a company
actually does?
Of course, we go to the company website
itself.
So we go to the company website.
We also go to the investor relations
website of the company.
And from these sources, we learn about
what the company actually does.
And we increase our qualitative
understanding of the company.
When we want to start sourcing our key
performance indicators, we move from the
company website to the investor relations
website.
And we start looking for sources where we
can locate key performance indicators and
the management operating plan.
We find on the website.
We find on the website for investor
relations, an area called events and
presentations.
And these are generally conferences or
events where the company itself is
pitching investors to invest in the
business.
So these events are generally attended by
not only investors, but also investment
bank analysts that report on the stock and
also have research models and ratings and
price targets.
What we also tend to find in this area is
presentations where the company is
updating shareholders with updates
between, so updates on the business
between earnings releases.
So when we are looking to source key
performance indicators or a company, any
company, we always look to the investor
relations website and we navigate towards
events and presentations.
And we seek to source clues of key
performance indicators, evidence of key
performance indicators and updates to
shareholders on the business so we can
build out our KPI list.
So we went through this process for you
here in this example with Zendesk.
We clicked into presentations and what we
found was is a list of shareholder letters
with updates on the business.
So what you will find is with all
companies on investor relations websites
is that company events and presentations
provide us with an insight into what
management are focused on.
And this is great for us in identifying
what metrics other than say revenue and
earnings the company actually focuses on.
These are the drivers of the business and
they infer the management operating plan.
In these presentations guys, management is
literally telling you in plain English
what the drivers of their business are.
So there is literally no excuse not to do
the work.
It's a few clicks away to get to sources
where you can actually start listing the
key performance indicators in the
qualitative assessment for any company out
there.
You've just got to know where to look and
you have to go through your processes and
you have to interpret the information.
And of course, this requires a bit of
practice.
But over time, you're going to get quicker
at this process and you're going to get
better at interpreting the qualitative
information, the KPIs and the management
operating plan.
So what we did here with this example with
Zendesk, we clicked into the last publicly
available shareholder letter.
And this is what we found.
So firstly, we found in the opening slide
that $1 billion of revenue, the top line
target was the target for the last four
years.
And Zendesk achieved it by hitting $1.03
billion in 2020, which was revenue growth
of 26% versus revenue in 2019.
Now, remember, this is a financial metric
and our primary concern here is
qualitative, not quantitative information.
However, of course, when we go through
presentations and shareholder letters,
there are going to be quantitative
elements that we do take note of.
Now, in this opening of the last
shareholder letter that's available, they
admit that towards the end of the year,
the business conditions were much stronger
than the beginning of the year because of
COVID-19.
So they're implying that there's a V shape
in earnings or 2020 instead of an expected
linear progression, which they didn't
expect.
So they're ending the year in a strong
growth position.
So we just take note of these things and
we keep scrolling through the presentation
and keep picking up on important
information.
So further into the presentation, we get
to more financial metrics.
So here we're being told by management of
a target to triple their revenue within
five years.
And we are also given the official
management guidance for the next quarter
Q1 and the full year ahead.
So this again is financial metrics, but
it's important information that we take
note of because we're building a context
in which the KPIs of the company exist.
It's the management operating plan and the
KPIs that are driving these numbers.
They are behind these numbers.
So we continue scrolling through the
presentation.
We continue taking notes of important
information.
We continue with our qualitative
assessment and we get to the next piece of
importance information in the shareholder
letter where we have several metrics that
must be important to the company.
It must be important to the management
operating plan and investors.
Those being ticket volume, gross bookings,
quarterly new business and expansion
bookings.
Remember guys, in these presentations, in
these updates to shareholders, management
are literally telling you in English what
is important to the business.
So in this case, we have our KPIs indexed
new tickets and indexed bookings.
So new business and expansion business.
And we take note that it's close to 60%.
So both measures are showing a rate of
growth of 60%.
We continue to dig deeper, we continue to
make notes on KPIs and we get to further
slides which show us more qualitative
information that we take note of.
It seems that it seems that the company is
now shifting its pricing plans from
individual products, plans and add-ons to
an aggregated solution.
And pricing is on a per agent or
subscription basis per month.
So in this presentation, they are updating
shareholders and investors in the company
that they are literally shifting their
business model.
And remember, if this is an update to
shareholders and investors in the company,
this is also a pitch for the future of the
company to investors and shareholders.
Because they are changing the way they do
business.
They are tweaking their business model as
they grow.
As we continue through the presentation,
we also take note that the following
metrics must be important to the
management operating plan and investors.
Because they are literally updating the
reader, shareholders or investors on these
numbers.
So they have to be important.
Again, guys, they are literally telling
you in the presentation what is important
to the business in terms of key
performance indicators and therefore the
management operating plan.
It's right there in black and white.
So we have a dollar-based net expansion
rate number that we take note of.
And we have the percentage of annual
recurring revenue, ARR, from enterprise
customers.
So we take note of these KPIs and the
targets, the numbers that are important to
the company.
So dollar-based net expansion rate of
between 110 and 120%.
The percentage of total annual recurring
revenue, ARR, by 100K plus customers, 49%.
And percentage of support ARR generated by
customers with 100 plus agents, 44%.
And what the company is saying on the
right-hand side in the bottom paragraph is
that these customers, the 100K plus and
the 100 plus agent customers, so
enterprise customers,
are increasingly impacting their revenues
as they continue to aggressively grow even
the number of small and medium or
mid-sized businesses using their products.
So this is great information as we're
going through this presentation.
We're building up a list of KPIs now.
So we continue scrolling.
We continue our investigation.
We continue picking out the KPIs and
inferring the management operating plan.
So we get further into the presentation
here.
And again, we take note of further metrics
that must be important to the management
operating plan and shareholders.
So we have a metric here called remaining
performance obligations in millions of
dollars.
And of course, the company would not even
put this in the presentation if it wasn't
materially important to the company.
They wouldn't put it in the presentation,
guys.
So again, they're literally telling you
what is important.
What are the important KPIs in how they
measure their operation, their business?
So we make a list of these KPIs and we
attach the numbers for the KPIs to the
KPIs in the last update.
So here for remaining performance
obligations, we have total RPO percentage
growth at 44%.
We have long term RPO percentage growth at
65%.
And we have short term RPO percentage
growth at 36%.
Now, you're probably sitting there
wondering, well, Anton, what if I'm coming
into this cold and I don't know what any
of this means?
Well, what you've got to understand this
here is that you're going through a
process that's repeatable in any
situation.
If you don't know what remaining
performance obligations are or you don't
know what dollar based net expansion rate
is or annual recurring revenue.
Of course, we can go elsewhere to find out
that information.
What we are doing here is going through a
process to first identify the KPIs.
Later, we can go elsewhere to discover
what they actually are.
So if you are coming into this cold with
no knowledge, how do you think we figure
this out?
How do we figure out what this all means?
We'll come on to this a little bit later.
Now further on in this presentation, in
this example, we can take note of customer
acquisition numbers and we can work out
ourselves in a spreadsheet, a percentage
growth rate for each product suite for the
year 2020.
So in the customer metrics that are
available in the presentation, so this is
all publicly available.
Remember, in the quarter on quarter
customer metrics, we get the following.
We have accounts at Zendesk support.
We have accounts at Zendesk chat.
We have the accounts on other Zendesk
products and we have total customer
accounts.
So the growth in all of these areas of
customers are in fact themselves KPIs.
So we can calculate this ourselves in a
spreadsheet.
It's very straightforward.
So accounts at Zendesk support.
We have positive 2% to 3% growth quarter
on quarter.
We have accounts on Zendesk chat.
We have from negative 2% to negative 3%
growth in that product quarter on quarter.
We have accounts on other Zendesk
products.
So we see 8% to 9% growth quarter on
quarter.
And then we have total customer accounts,
which are growing up between 2% and 3%
quarter on quarter.
So this guys is an example of taking
information from the presentations, taking
that information and actually going a
little bit further and doing our own work.
Don't be afraid to do your own work and
always ask the questions.
Throughout this whole process, you are a
detective and you're looking to get to the
bottom of why the company is valued at a
premium to the sector.
And in the qualitative phase, we can take
information from presentations, from
conferences and events.
And we can take that qualitative
information and we can turn it into
numbers and we can turn it into key
performance indicators.
That is important information to the
management operating plan.
And this is a very obvious one.
This is customer acquisition across its
main products and in total.
But in the presentation here, they're not
giving us the percentage numbers.
So we work it out ourselves.
It's very straightforward.
And it's pretty obvious that a key
performance indicator of any business and
a business like Zendesk is the customer
acquisition growth rate.
So don't be afraid to think outside the
box a little bit and do your own work.
Now, as we scroll further through the
presentation, we come across some
important information to do with
geographical business.
So we take note of another qualitative
metric of the geographical revenue mix.
And we note that roughly half of Zendesk's
revenue originates from the US and half of
it internationally.
And we infer that what this means in this
particular case with Zendesk is that if
the US dollar was to have a significant
rally versus rest of world currencies,
that this can potentially derail revenue
growth.
When local currency revenue that's in the
rest of the world is translated back into
US dollars because their accounts are
denominated in US dollars.
So we take note of qualitative information
like this because it could provide a
headwind, which is in a strong dollar
environment.
And it could provide a tailwind in a weak
dollar environment.
But at this stage, we just don't know
because we don't know whether they hedge
their overseas currency exposure, their
overseas sales exposure.
Now, earlier, we mentioned that there are
places to go to if you don't understand
certain KPIs or certain metrics when you
are going through your qualitative
process.
When you're sitting at your desk, you're
going through your processes, your
qualitative process.
You see KPIs and metrics, the names of
them from presentations.
You don't understand what they mean.
Where do you think you go to?
Well, a good start would just be to Google
it.
In the vast majority of situations, when
you're going through your qualitative
processes, if you don't understand what a
particular KPI is all about.
Yes, you go through your processes, you
identify them.
But when you want to understand what they
are, Google is your friend.
Stick it into Google and start reading up
on it.
So the other alternative is to go through
your processes and when you get to a KPI
that you've identified and you don't know
what it's all about, you just sit there
and give up.
Well, of course not.
Of course, you're not going to give up.
You're going to type it into Google and
you're going to learn about it.
So in this example with Zendesk, if you
were going through this cold and for the
first time and you didn't understand what
dollar-based net expansion rate was, you
would type it into Google and you would
literally read about it and teach yourself
about it.
So we have literally on the top of the
first page of Google.
In this example, when we put in
dollar-based net expansion rate, we have
an article from Crunchbase, which gives
you the formula and tells you all about
it.
It will take you 5-10 minutes to read up
on it.
And then we also have various articles
that are telling us and inferring what a
net dollar retention rate benchmark would
be for the software as a service industry.
So you have to get used to being curious
guys, and relying on yourself and going
out there and getting the information
yourself, becoming self-reliant.
So you would naturally Google terms that
you don't understand, start reading up on
them and start information gathering so
you can learn yourself and teach yourself.
Another one in this example was annual
recurring revenue.
And we can just Google it.
We can literally type into Google ARR
meaning.
And in this example, if you were clicking
through articles and information online to
find out about ARR, you would literally be
told the formula for annual recurring
revenue.
It's all very straightforward.
And again, with our last one, remaining
performance obligations.
If you didn't know it, and you were coming
in cold, and you really just didn't know
what it was, you would go to Google, just
type it in, and there's plenty of sources
out there.
This will happen with a lot of companies
that you do research on, a lot of
companies that you go through your
qualitative processes on.
And if you don't understand anything, just
take it to the next logical step.
Go into Google, type it in, and teach
yourself what it's all about to further
your understanding of the company.
And of course, the key performance
indicators, the KPIs.
If you go through these steps, and you're
curious, and you can teach yourself, and
you're self-reliant, you are always going
to bump into the answers.
You are going to get the information.
So be organized, and stick to the process,
be curious, and be self-reliant.
So from this example, from Zendesk, and
going through that shareholder update,
shareholder letter, we can get to some
answers for KPIs very, very quickly.
So let's go through them.
We've created a dashboard in a very short
space of time for Zendesk KPIs.
So let's start at the top.
We have indexed new tickets, indexed
bookings for new business and expansion
business.
And for both of those areas, we had a
growth rate of 60%.
We have dollar-based net expansion rate of
between 110 and 120%.
We have the percentage of total ARR by
$100,000 and over customers of 49%.
And we have the percentage of support ARR
generated by customers with over 100
agents at 44%.
We have long-term RPO percentage growth at
65%.
Short-term RPO percentage growth at 36%.
And we have a total of RPO percentage
growth of 44%.
For customer acquisition growth rates
across the products, we have accounts at
Zendesk support of growth rates 2% to 3%
quarter on quarter.
Accounts at Zendesk chat quarter on
quarter growth at negative 2% to negative
3%.
Accounts on other Zendesk products, growth
rates of between 8% and 9% quarter on
quarter, giving total customer accounts of
growth rates quarter on quarter of 2% to
3%.
So what we discovered here from one
presentation in a very short space of
time, we've identified the key metrics
beneath revenue and earnings.
And this is what drives revenue and
earnings.
What you are looking at here is the
business and how the business is measured
and the measurements that drive revenue
and earnings, which are the results.
They are the end financial results.
So these are the key performance
indicators of the operation of the
company.
In addition to helping us understand and
potentially forecasting future revenue and
earnings growth, the KPIs of the company
are also a measure of the effectiveness of
the company's management operating plan.
And as mentioned previously, there is no
one place with any company that you can go
to where they literally spell out what the
management operating plan is.
We have to identify the KPIs first and
then infer what the management operating
plan is.
And we do this work ourselves.
So for Zendesk as the example, what
information can we take away that can
infer from the KPIs what the management
operating plan is?
Well, we started by recognizing that the
company is targeting to triple revenue
within five years to over $3 billion.
And in the year 2021, grow revenue by 26%
revenue growth, a rate of 26% revenue
growth in 2021.
But then we have to make an inferral.
How are they going to achieve this?
Well, we look to their KPIs and we infer
this, therefore inferring a management
operating plan.
So in terms of customer acquisition,
they're going to have to grow total
customer accounts at a rate of at least 2%
to 3% per quarter.
And that's breaking it down into Zendesk
support, chat and products, other
products.
They're going to have to grow Zendesk
support by at least 2% to 3% acquisition
rate per quarter.
So we're going to have to stop the bleed
at Zendesk.
Stop the bleed at Zendesk chat,
potentially by bundling the service.
So if you remember with Zendesk chat, they
were actually negative acquisition,
customer acquisition.
So they were losing customers there.
And they were also pitching how they were
moving into a new business model of
bundling.
So we have inferred here that they're
looking to stop the bleed at Zendesk chat
by bundling the service.
Other Zendesk products that they sell into
current customers was growing at the
highest rate, which was 8% to 9%
acquisition per quarter.
And these products are now potentially
being moved to bundled packages.
So as they're moving to a bundled service,
they're going to have to obviously grow
the bundled packages at a blended average
that is higher or at least the same as the
total customer accounts acquisition rate
per quarter, which was the 2% to 3%.
They will have to do at least that in the
new bundled business model.
In addition to that, an important KPI was
our dollar-based net expansion rate.
So the company in their inferred
management operating plan is most probably
seeking to maintain that rate of between
110% and 120%.
Additionally, as inferred by the KPIs, our
next KPI was ARR.
So the company is most probably seeking in
the future to continue to achieve a
healthy mix in their ARR from enterprise
clients versus small and midsize
businesses.
And in addition to that, to deliver on our
next KPI metric, remaining performance
obligations to deliver on RPOs via their
customer retention.
So you can see, guys, very quickly by just
going to events and presentations on the
investor relations website of a company,
we can source presentations that are very
recent and we can find, identify key
performance indicators.
We can create, in a very short space of
time, a dashboard or key performance
indicators.
And from that, we can infer a management
operating plan.
Now, once we've got our KPIs and we've
inferred our management operating plan, we
ask ourselves a number of questions of the
KPIs themselves.
So, for example, what will change revenue
and earnings up or down?
What's going to move the needle of revenue
and earnings?
How does the company measure its operation
other than revenue and earnings?
How is the company achieving its superior
growth?
Or why is it suffering from its inferior
What are these other financial metrics,
our KPIs, actually telling us?
What are they showing?
What do we think the outlook is for KPIs
and the management operating plan and the
changes or potential changes in the future
of the management operating plan?
So the intentions and targets of the KPIs
and the inferred MOP.
And also, how long will it continue?
So we continually ask ourselves these
questions as we are going through
identifying KPIs and then understanding
the KPIs.
We continually ask ourselves these
questions to ensure discipline in
understanding what the evidence is behind
revenue and earnings growth.
We are not just looking at these KPIs and
inferring a management operating plan for
fun.
We are doing it to find out what is
driving the business and hence what is
driving the revenue and earnings growth.
So in the context of a premium stock that
is growing faster than the sector, what we
want to know is the measurements, the KPIs
that are behind that and whether the rates
of those KPIs, so the numbers behind those
KPIs, actually support and justify the
premium valuation.
Does the qualitative assessment back up
the quantitative assessment?
So let's put all this together and
summarize in the first stage of the
qualitative assessment.
So remember the context that we're in
here.
We have our quant discovery phase.
We have our quant evidence phase.
And we have our qualitative phase.
In our quant discovery phase, we are
utilizing forward looking valuation to
identify or discover positive and negative
outliers and everything else in between
like turnarounds or potential value traps.
In the quant evidence phase.
We are looking to backwards looking
financial statements to provide evidence
to support valuation.
And then we move into the qualitative
phase.
phase where we are looking at backwards
and forwards looking KPIs and inferring a
management operating plan.
And we are looking at the drivers of the
business.
The key drivers of the business, which are
the KPIs.
Do they provide evidence to support
valuation?
And within that qualitative assessment, we
are always remembering that we operate in
the framework where we identify KPIs.
This infers the management operating plan.
And the MOP and the KPIs drive the
quantitative results, the financial
metrics like revenue and earnings.
They drive the financial quantitative
results of the company.
So beneath those results, revenue and
earnings, there is always something that
creates that result.
There is a business and this business is
driven by the management operating plan.
And it's measured by key performance
indicators.
So we need to keep asking ourselves the
questions.
Why is earnings growth or revenue growth
so good or bad?
Why does the market value the company in
the way that it does?
Does the stock deserve to be on its
assigned premium or discount?
Will the company continue to report good
numbers, beating expectations in revenue
and earnings?
Or, in the case of a negative outlier,
continue to report bad numbers, missing
expectations?
Based on our assessment of the KPIs, is it
likely, is it probable that because of the
KPIs that the company is going to continue
to report good numbers and beat
expectations?
Or, probable in a negative outlier context
that the company is going to report bad
numbers and missing expectations?
Is it high probability?
And also, are there any additional
catalysts to earnings day that will get
the stock moving higher or lower in
between earnings reports?
That's something we're going to move on to
soon when we look at catalysts.
So we keep asking ourselves these
questions throughout our qualitative
assessment.
We first, obviously, identify KPIs and
then we infer the management operating
plan.
We know this is how companies measure
themselves.
This is how they get to their own guidance
for numbers.
So how they get to their guidance when
they're forecasting and updating their
revenue and earnings estimates for
analysts.
And it's also how analysts measure the
company's performance to enable them to
forecast revenue and earnings outcomes
and, therefore, the analyst expectations.
If we have any positive or negative
changes in the KPIs, that's going to mean
a change in expectations of future revenue
and earnings forecasts and other
operational metrics.
The stock itself will immediately move on
KPI news and analysts will follow by
upgrading or downgrading their ratings and
price targets.
This is why KPIs are so important because
the business and how it's measured moves
before the actual results that are
reported, the revenue and earnings on
earnings day.
So we have to identify KPIs, we have to
infer the management operating plan, and
we have to stay on top of anything that
can change those KPIs.
So this brings us now to the end of our
first step in the qualitative processing
phase.
Let's go straight in to the next video
into the second part of the qualitative
processing phase.
Thank you.